Our Generation we are not strong like
you are I think like I don't I don't
agree I look at you and I I literally am
sad because I think like I want that for
you I want you to think differently I
want you to think that to Value yourself
and to think like you are worthy of that
and there's not you know just talk about
the men mostly I think like the guys who
are attending the provider who's going
to protect the house I wish all the men
could represent this kind of security
but our generation I have the feeling
they maybe they've been with less trauma
less things they are not the tough
there's less of them there is less of
them but there's also less competition
for good quality women I mean there's so
you know the just let all the trash hang
out at the gutter and go rise up